Many female spiders are subjected to an insult
on their genitals in terms of something called
a mating plug.
The ejaculates of many males contain substances
that are specifically designed to ‘seal
up’ a female's’ genital openings once
their sperm has been deposited.
The function of these mating plugs (aka chastity
belts) is to deter any future suitors from
adding their sperm to the mix.
The entire notion of the mating plug seems
ultra-unfair to the females that receive them;
however, that’s not always the case.
Although it may initially seem counterintuitive,
it’s often the females that are plugging
themselves up.
However, that’s not always the case.
Although it may initially seem counterintuitive,
it’s often the females that are plugging
themselves up.
And there are actually a number of good reasons
for them to want to do this.
First off, to protect themselves from unwanted
acts of sex.
Giant wood spider females are solely responsible
for production of a hardened plate over their
genital openings.
These plates are highly effective at preventing
any kind of sexual advances - basically, males
are virtually unable to insert their pedipalps
(penises) into her.
Other females put their copulatory plugs to
more sinister use.
Females of an orb weaving species secrete
a sticky substance from their genital ducts
that functions to entrap unsuspecting males
by their penises.This gives the females ample
time and opportunity to cannibalize the would-be
suitors.
There are also cases where both males and
females work together to produce a mating
plug - a sort of ‘happy medium’ if you
will.
In another orb weaver , males deposit their
sperm along with their ‘half’ of the mating
plug.
If a female is happy with her male partner,
she can secrete the other half of the plug
in order to create a lasting seal (think of
it as two part epoxy).
If she is not happy with her male partner,
she will not add her magic glue to his plug,
resulting in both the plug liquid and his
sperm trickling out of her body and out of
her life.
So yes, it’s true that the notion of a chastity
belt is not generally a fun one for females
in the animal kingdom.
But you can rest assured that some ladies
out there continue to thrive by creating mating
plugs that work to their own (female) advantage.
Want to see more animal videos?
Then check out this playlist from our friends
at The Dodo.
Don't forget to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.